>> Tucker: 2020 PRESIDENTIAL
CAMPAIGN ALREADY UNDERWAY.
DOZENS OF CANDIDATES IN THE
RACE AND POSSIBLY DOZENS
MORE TO COME.
ON THE REPUBLICAN SIDE THERE
IS JUST THE INCUMBENT
PRESIDENT.
EVERYONE ASSUMES HE WANTS TO
BE REELECTED MOST PRESIDENTS
DO.
WHAT IF DONALD TRUMP HAD
DECIDED HE HAS HAD ENOUGH?
TOO MANY INVESTIGATIONS, TOO
MUCH NASTINESS, TOO FEW
UPSIDES.
IT WOULDN'T BE A CRAZY
CONCLUSION.
HOW WOULD YOU LIKE TO SPEND
YOUR 70'S LOCKED INTO THE
WHITE HOUSE?
LET'S SAY TRUMP WANTS TO
LOSE IN 2020 AND GET BACK TO
HIS OLD LIFE?
HOW WE DO THAT?
LET'S SEE, HE MIGHT START BY
PROPOSING HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN MEDICARE CUTS.
THAT'S SOMETHING THAT NOBODY
OUTSIDE THE LIBERTARIAN
SYMPOSIA CIRCUIT WANTS TO
SEE.
DO YOU THAT THEN HE WOULD
SLASH FUNDING FOR THE
EVERIFY PROGRAM ALLOW
COMPANIES TO KEEP HIRING
ILLEGAL LABOR IN VIOLATION
OF A KEY CAMPAIGN PROMISE.
AFTER THAT HE WOULD DENOUNCE
BRINGING IN EVEN MORE LOW
SKILLED WORKERS THAT WOULD
PUSH DOWN THE WAGES OF THE
PEOPLE WHO VOTED FOR HIM.
THE MOST VULNERABLE GROUP IN
THE COUNTRY.
FINALLY HE WOULD RELEASE A
BUNCH OF DRUG DEALERS RIGHT
BACK ON THE STREETS RIGHT IN
THE MIDDLE OF THE WORST DRUG
EPIDEMIC IN HISTORY AND
CONTINUE OUR POINTLESS
MILITARY INTERVENTION IN
SYRIA WHICH IN NO WAY
BENEFITS THE UNITED STATES.
IF THE PRESIDENT DID ALL OF
THAT, THE MESSAGE WOULD BE
VERY CLEAR, HE HAS NO IDEA
WHAT HE RAN ON IN 2016, HE
JUST WANTS OUT.
WELL LET'S SAY VOTERS STILL
DIDN'T GET THE MESSAGE.
MAYBE THEY WERE TOO
DISTRACTED BY THE RUSSIA
HOAX TO NOTICE?
AT THAT POINT YOU HAVE TO DO
SOMETHING REALLY EXTREME TO
GET THEIR ATTENTION,
SOMETHING SO MINDLESS AND
COUNTER PRODUCTIVE THERE IS
LITERALLY  NO WAY TO GET
REELECTED AFTER DOING IT.
YOU WOULD RAISE GAS TAXES.
IN FACT THE ADMINISTRATION
IS PROPOSING JUST THAT
ACCORDING TO NEWS REPORTS
THE WHITE HOUSE IS
NEGOTIATING WITH DEMOCRATS
TO HIKE TAXES ON GASOLINE IN
ORDER TO FUND, QUOTE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE IDEAS
THAT EVERYONE IN WASHINGTON
LOVES.
IT COSTS THEM NOTHING.
THEY ARE TOO RICH TO CARE
WHAT GAS COSTS AND BY THE
WAY THEY DON'T DRIVE.
IF YOU LIVE OUTSIDE THE
COASTAL CITIES AND NOT RICH,
HIGHER GAS PRICES ARE A
DISASTER.
THEY HURT YOU IMMEDIATELY.
THAT'S ALWAYS TRUE ANYTHING
THAT RAISES THE PRICE OF
GASOLINE GREEN NEW DEAL OR
RAISES THE PRICE OF GASOLINE
THINK TANKS CRUSHES THE
WEAKEST IN OUR SOCIETY.
NORMAL PEOPLE HATE IT MANY
OF THOSE PEOPLE VOTED FOR
DONALD TRUMP THE FIRST TIME.
IT'S NUTS.
AND IT'S NOT LIKE THERE
AREN'T OTHER SMARTER LESS
REGRESSIVE OPTIONS IF YOU
WANT TO RAISE MONEY THERE
ARE MANY OF THEM.
ROLL BACK SOME OF THOSE 2017
TAX CUTS WHICH WENT
OVERWHELMINGLY TO HIGH
EARNERS AND BIG COMPANIES.
BILLIONS OF REMITTANCE IN
THE UNITED STATES TO THE
REST OF THE WORLD.
REMEMBER THAT IDEA?
REDUCE CARRIED INTEREST LIKE
THE INCOME IT SO OBVIOUSLY
IS WE SHOULD DO THAT ANYWAY
JUST ON PRINCIPLE.
EVEN TAX CAPITAL GAINS LIKE
WE TAX SALARIES.
MITT ROMNEY MIGHT FINALLY
PATE SAME RATE AS YOUR
DENTIST AND THAT WOULD BE
SATISFYING.  AND THEN WE
COULD GET CREATIVE.
HOW ABOUT ABOUT 80% TAX ON
ALL LOBBYING PRODUCED BY
FORMER MEMBERS OF CONGRESS.
THAT'S A GOOD ONE.
HOW ABOUT AN IPHONE TAX?
OR HOW ABOUT A TOUGH NEW TAX
ON A TRILLION-DOLLAR BASED
INTERNET DEALER WHOSE BASE
PUBLIC ROADS TO DELIVER
THEIR PACKAGES?
COMPANIES LIKE THAT HAVE PUT
AN AWFUL LOT OF AMERICAN
BUSINESSES OUT OF WORK.
THEY CLOG OUR ROADS.
WHY AREN'T THEY PAYING FOR
INFRASTRUCTURE?
WE COULD GO ON PLENTY OF
OBVIOUS IDEAS OUT THERE.
HIKING TAXES ON WORKING
CLASS RURAL PEOPLE IS NOT ON
THE LIST.
UNLESS YOU SECRETLY WANT TO